people are now in new york city starting  to fight against these da's  because this looks like complete  insanity and everybody knows you could  be next  you're a store owner out there  you have a store somebody walks in and  does this what are you gonna you're  gonna be afraid to defend yourself  you are going to be afraid to defend  yourself  because you're going to be afraid well i  can't i can't wind up in rikers with a  250 000 bill what am i going to do so  what's that guy supposed to do just get  stabbed  take whatever you want from my store oh  you don't you don't have your ebt card  doesn't work don't worry just take the  snack oh and by the way stab me don't  worry  it's fine  this is the world we're living in this  is what new york is perpetuating and  this is why people don't want to live  there anymore this is why people don't  want their families to be there anymore  because it's unsafe